Every year, especially at the end of the year,...
...we see several high - profile figures...
...like billionaire Warren Buffett...
...donating to the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation,...
...and of course it is used to support charity.
What I want to point out is that...
...dollar amounts are important,...
...but there is more to charitable giving than just the act of writing out checks.
When we donate money to someone or something else,...
...we are giving something of ourselves,...
...don't you think?
It is not an easy thing to do,...
...giving away as much as you can possibly afford.
We are making a statement about what is most important to us.
This is not something to be taken lightly.
It is a true sacrifice.
You mentioned that you like doing charitable giving,...
...am I correct?
You are right.
After spending about 5 years in a nonprofit organization,...
...I realized that donating is not a casual activity,...
...but when you do it,...
...you can make it more meaningful.
You should carefully plan,..
...carefully target and carefully evaluate.
Do you see what I'm getting at?
Doing charity work is important,...
...but giving effectively is more crucial.
It requires love,...
...but also requires deliberation and thoughtfulness.
But a giving heart is not enough.
We also need to use our heads when we give,...
...seeking to maximize the effectiveness of the gifts we make.